where'd you get the name
soft boy
um I mean I guess you know there's like
three different answers for that okay
one of one of them is blue oyster cult's
original name but that's not really why
okay
um
back when I was a kid I remember hearing
my dad's
like business associates talk about the
soft underbelly of whatever you know
talking about the vulnerable part of
whatever whatever the subject was at the
time yeah good and I think Winston
Churchill referred to Italy as the soft
underbelly of Europe okay back when uh
World War II was going out yeah all
right that's very good I like that so
that's where the name came from Jeremy
where are you from originally all right
I'm originally from uh Toronto Canada
and uh I was born there and uh you know
grew up there until I was just seven and
then my parents
uh my dad especially wanted to leave
Canada because he was just over the
the winners and all that so my mom's dad
was out here
and uh he actually ran a little shop uh
like a
kind of like a cowboy shop I guess for
like boots and Saddles and all that and
uh up in Glendale so they would come out
here and visit so they were familiar
with it but no family out here and so
once he passed we moved out here when I
was seven and uh he passed away shortly
after that but so it was just us
you know no other family no aunts no
uncles no nothing everybody else is in
Canada hmm how would you describe your
childhood
it was good yeah my childhood was good
I mean it was a little weird so
give me a little insight so my mom's mom
had a sister
Three Brothers
and uh
two of the brothers in one of the
scissors were gay
so she they didn't have kids right and
so it was and they all lived in one
house
so like her upbringing was a little
weird too right she was always taking
care of her mom her mom was sick a lot
and so my mom took took care of her a
lot but it was also weird you know
growing up with
um
that whole crew you know in one house
and
um my aunt is actually you know did you
ever hear uh what's that movie where it
was Madonna the baseball movie
uh
I forget what it's called I forget the
name damn okay anyway she was like one
of those players on the baseball team
yeah it's a great movie yeah so that was
cool and then uh but so with my mom and
dad both working I was with my uncle a
lot and my aunt at that house it's a big
ass house it's a big it was the biggest
house on the Block like if you look down
the block all these one-story houses in
Canada it's big [__] house right the
middle of the Block it's just it's still
there
funniest [__] ever I looked it up on
Google Maps it's pretty funny
but anyway so
so anyway you know we're out here and
and most of her family passed away and
so we're pretty much on our own it's
just the five of us uh my mom my dad me
I'm the oldest and my sister and brother
so uh you know growing up was cool
like I said I uh
grew up out here and then once I got
into High School junior high you know
started partying got in the dope and
stuff and then
I can't remember exactly when but
I remember a a visit to the dentist
to get my wisdom teeth taken out and uh
that's when I got into pills and I think
that was like 15 16. and then I was I
was just off and running
so then through high school I was
popping pills
and it was kind of funny because
back in the 90s like you'd be at a party
and I'd have a handful of pills and
people are like what's going on dude you
have a headache or something I'm like
I'm like no they're Vicodin they're like
what
what you know
so nobody really nobody really was into
that you know so it was kind of like I
was uh
I was like uh
into it way before anybody else saved me
so
but so once I got a job I got a job
cleaning windows and uh
cleaning windows is not a necessity it's
a luxury so I uh worked most of the time
in high-end homes rich people's homes
and for some reason in the 90s doctors
were just I don't know what it was but I
would go into medicine cabinets and big
homes and
ninety percent of the time they'd have a
huge bottle of Vicodin
Oxycontin you know whatever Percocets
and so
that's how I got my dough
it was kind of funny because writing
their medicine cabinet yeah like I
wasn't I wasn't going in there and like
taking a Rolex or you know doing any of
the normal junky [__] I was just going
into their medicine cabinet you know I'd
pass all the you know the the Gucci
shoes and all these other [__] I could
have gotten rid of and just went for the
medicine cabinet so it was kind of funny
because
another thing was is I had to go to work
to get dope so that's what kept me
employed you know what I'm saying so
it's like I had to just and then the
weekends kind of sucked because I wasn't
working so I have to like
you know I'd have to clock everything so
it made it to Sunday and you know
sometimes you get sick and and that was
just I think the first time I got sick I
was I didn't really get it I was like
what the [__] is wrong with me I'm like
do I have a flu or something you know
most junkies don't really get it the
first time
and then you know one of your friends
will be like oh yeah you're dope sick
and you're like oh [__] is that what
this is [__] this
and that's when you try really hard
not to get dope sick
so uh so yeah that's what I did most of
my time is go to work so I was a super
employee so I was at work every
[__] day you get dope it was
funny because you've lived on the
streets and no no
what right now no I mean in your time no
no back then no I was employed and I
didn't pay for dope
so I was [__] balling I you know I
had pills I had money I had a job at a
car a girlfriend all sorts of [__] and
uh you know I was also plugged into the
uh to the rage scene from from the early
90s up until like 99 and that was a huge
that was a huge part of my life uh
ecstasy all that all the you know exotic
drugs Special K we used to drive down to
Mexico and
get Special K and bring it back and
yeah I've had some crazy ass stories
Mexico
so one time we went down there we used
to go get oxycontins
in Tijuana which is weird because uh and
oxycontins are manufactured in the U.S
so that means somebody in the 90s was
taking oxycontins across the border in
Mexico to sell them at a pharmacy back
to college kids you know at San Diego
because you can buy drugs pharmaceutical
drugs yeah but they don't have Vicodin
or anything the only thing they have
there like out of Pharmacy that they
manufacture is Cody that's it can't get
Vicodin Perks at any of that [__]
you can buy that stuff without a without
a prescription correct you know and yeah
you can get uh gear like uh steroids any
of that kind of stuff but you know but
we thought it was so weird there's like
we're like there's Oxycontin 30s here
like what what's going on and this was
way before fentanyl so they weren't
pressing them this was the real [__]
like coming in a package like from the
U.S because we couldn't figure what the
[__] going on it's so weird anyway it
was a good plug so we go down there a
lot and uh you know it's before cell
phones so we went we could we wouldn't
call down there we just wing it we just
jump on the [__] freeway at like
Tuesday you know eight o'clock at night
let's go get the moxies boom and uh me
and my boy went one night and we'd
always Park
and walk across so one night we parked
we walked across we're on Revolution
Street and uh
you know we go but some guy's like oh
yeah I can get you Viking because our
Pharmacy didn't have any oxygons so of
course we were walking with some dude
[__] we I'm like okay we're off
revolutions right now I don't know where
we're at dude it's gonna get weird and
it got [__] weird so now we're in
some strip club
all this and my boy goes outside smokes
here or something and the next thing I
know the federalities I see them through
a window and they're taking them away
and I'm like hey dude what the [__] is
going on over here and so I go outside
nobody's out there it's like a ghost I
don't know where they went I didn't see
him even a car it was like [__] gone
and so now I'm like hey what happened he
goes oh they must have taken him to jail
I go the [__] are you talking about he's
got he's my ride oh wait you're gonna
have to go get him out all right [__] it
so I take a taxi to every jail
and ask hey you know is so-and-so here
no he's not here
last jail I I checked was like 12 miles
into Tijuana and I ran out of money so
now I'm on foot
walking back
to the border and it's like two or three
in the morning and like I'm just looking
around going like what the [__] like a
Van's gonna pull up and I'm just gonna
get disappeared into some weird you know
[__] 55 gallon drums somewhere and
then it's funny because I'm you know I'm
keeping an eye out and out of the corner
of my eye I can see at the gas station
there's this dude and he's like he's
like watching me you know and so I'm
watching him and I'm walking I'm just
keep walking
and I'm like this [__] guy's like
really like interested or something you
know what I'm saying like he's just like
[__] weird it's like oh great okay so
now he pulls out and then he's pulling
up to me and I go what the [__] and he
pulls up puts his window down and then
he goes hey what are you doing and I go
uh walking
and then I see his kid in the back seat
and I go okay it's not gonna get too
[__] weird I hope right it's got like
a little small child in the back his son
or something he goes hey I'm uh I'm a
cop I'm I'm like a detective down here
and uh
I need you to get in the car because
there's [__] people watching you
right now and I go what and and I was in
the [__] car in like two seconds like
what are you talking about he goes yeah
um you're gonna get [__] kidnapped
and you're gonna get like you know it's
gonna be a weird situation where they're
gonna call you know your family you know
that kind of [__] happened you know and
so I'm like okay great so I tell him my
story of my friend and he goes all right
well let me you know let's go check
before cell phones we still had to drive
around and all but at least he could
communicate you know I'm up there going
hey my friend you know and they're just
like dude what the get the [__] out of
here
um
and so he checks everything you know and
and nothing
and I go what the [__] you know what
happened and he goes look it's getting
you know it's early in the morning now
I'm gonna just take you to the border
and we'll see what you know you got to
see what happens like [__] you know
whatever I'm like 18 at the time so
so he drops me off I go across I walk
across the board I have no dope I'm just
a I'm not well I'm a kind of a mess and
there's like a Denny's down there or
some [__] like that and I'm walking and
it's kind of foggy you know
and I can see this figure walking
towards me and I go
my [__] friend and we just keep
walking and I'm like what the [__] the
whole time I guess the federalis just
took them to the board and dropped him
off
so I've been [__] looking for him for
three or four hours and he's been eating
you know bacon eggs [__] Denny's so
not cool man so anyway
Mexico story
so today you're uh so you're using what
uh
fetty and and a little bit of crack
sprinkled in how did you
oh just entered over to fentanyl oh so
okay here's a here's the other story so
uh
you know I like like I said 99 2000 I'm
uh you know I'm kind of going nowhere
I'm in my early 20s and uh my parents
are like listen uh you know you got to
figure something out because you're just
a [__] mess you know like come on
and uh
so I'm like okay and they go uh you know
you should go into the military and I go
okay none of our family like since my
you know great uncles or whatever in
Canada were in the military you know so
my brother went in the Marines like a
year before me so that was my only
you know a thing I knew about it
so anyway I take the ASVAB and I scored
really good and uh I was gonna have you
know I was gonna go in the Marines all
that good stuff and for some reason the
guy you know the person's supposed to
come pick you up and take you to uh the
Depot in L.A and you ship out well he
never came
and I'm like what the [__] that was
weird right
and so I didn't hear anything of it so
they go you know what I you know my
parents are like just listen you scored
really good on that Zab try the Air
Force so I went to the Air Force
recruiter kind of in the same you know
building Glendale
so I talked to them boom like April 2001
I'm going to boot camp
and now granted I've been doing speed
for the last like three years and I'm a
junkie and a mess so now I'm going to
boot camp nobody thought I was gonna
make it like 24 hours they thought I'd
just [__] you know hop a train home
or something
so I get to Texas I get through boot
camp everybody's totally shocked I go to
Tech School June 2001.
and uh get through that
I come home
and then I get my orders to Mountain
Home Idaho
and uh I drive to the base I get there
in August and two weeks later 9 11
happens
and then a week after that I was in the
desert
yeah building a base it's actually still
there today uh it's called lud it's the
centcom base
for anybody going in and out of the
Middle East you know they kind of go
through there so you went to where
guitar guitar yeah uh I went to uh
guitar and we built that base and uh it
became the centcom base just because uh
psab which was in Saudi Arabia got
bombed in 98 so they shut that base down
so anyway
um so yeah I went from being a crazy
tweaker selling my
you know air-conditioned box of the
window were [__] dope to
chasing
crazy people through the torabor
mountains and you know it's just [__]
weird like I'd be standing in the middle
of just going what the [__] is going on
this is crazy
I didn't even think I'd make it I didn't
think I'd make it through Texas boot
camp tag school any of that [__]
anyways okay I'm now I'm in Mountain
Home I come home from the desert did six
you know six months in the desert did
great got achievement medals all this
good [__] I'm doing good I'm sober for
the first time like 10 years
everything's good
um so you know what 2002 2003 2004 I get
married
uh and you know that goes good and 2005
I get out and we moved to Vegas and we
thought oh this is going to be good and
it was okay but like once again we had
no family right so
uh me and the wife have a baby and and
then I become a real estate agent and I
start doing pills again
right so
so then now check this out
so now I'm using my uh my my box to get
into
to get into lock boxes for sales on for
sale homes and now I'm going through
their [__] medicine cabinets so I'm
spending my whole day looking on the MLS
for homes that are for sale
I can get in the lock box and go into
the medicine cabinet and sometimes I'd
go into somebody's home because I'd
knock into and then I'd walk in and
somebody be in the [__] shower they'd
be like oh what the [__] yeah I'm like
oh sorry I knocked I want you know I
want to show your house
it was just [__] crazy I can't
believe uh you know I can't believe they
didn't say anything I'd be going into
like 15 homes a day just looking for
looking for pills
so anyway yeah that happened and then
I guess we'll go up to like what now
it's uh two thousand
eight uh you know we don't do Vegas we
come back here
we've got a daughter now and uh
and I get clean once I have my daughter
I get on Suboxone okay
good job because I said I'm not gonna do
dope and have kids you know just [__]
that so I got into boxing I'm doing
really good got a job at UPS supervisor
all these good [__] I'm at the airport
and uh
you know that I'm doing good
and then we have a son 2010 2011 my wife
comes to me and goes hey you know what I
don't feel like being a a mom right now
and I don't feel like being a wife and I
think I want you to take the kids and go
to your mom's and I go
huh
like we never thought we were good you
know what I'm saying everything was cool
but I guess she met somebody and you
know whatever the [__]
so I take the kids and I go to my mom's
and uh you know
I raise my kids for 10 years I didn't do
any dope
and then my parents retired two years
ago sold the house we all lived in moved
to Palm Desert the kids had to go to
their moms because I couldn't do it on
my own and go to work and send them to
school and all this [__]
so that's when I kind of went off the
[__] rails again and it just went bad
like you know I oh this was the other
funny situation so I move out right I
get an apartment and I look at all these
apartments and of course with my luck
the one apartment I move into I'm moving
next to a crackhead so I start talking
to him and you know I thought it'd be a
really good idea to start smoking crack
so then uh everything kind of dwindled
quickly and uh
in the meantime I did meet somebody
uh became a really good friend down here
and so when I you know lost all my [__]
in like six months smoking crack
uh I ended up down here on Crocker
and uh it was kind of a crazy experience
because uh you know you're you're you're
you're more or less camping but you're
you're [__] permanently camping yeah
and I came out here this is what I
always said too it's like
the the year I move outside we end the
[__] drought like now it's raining
every day I'm like what the [__] is
going on come on man can't be on skid
rows not camping oh it's [__]
ridiculous and okay hold on
I also it somewhere in the few years I
had gotten on methadone so I was on 100
milligrams another so I would fall
asleep in the chair in the tent
so I would fall asleep and I'd fall into
like the camping stove
and so yeah one night I have a really
cool scar
I uh I fell asleep and I slid into the
camping stove and I had a leather jacket
on
and a sweater and it went through all
that [__] in my arm
and I I woke up because you know you're
not really like it doesn't hurt at first
you know you don't feel it it's just I
don't know it's weird so I get up and
I'm like oh [__] and the two people I
had you know chilling in the tent with
me is they were smoking crack I was
asleep they go oh what the [__] we're
out of here this is just like dude I'm
not I'm not even dealing with this yet
and so I'm like oh [__] like I'm looking
at the jacket the jacket was [__]
just demolished it just it the whole
thing just melts it the leather is just
gone and I'm like what the [__] right
and I did that a few times like I just
fall into the camping because you you
know you kind of fall asleep around
just how it went
and so yeah I got a lot of [__] for that
um anyway so and I got really good
sleeping in the chair
so uh so yeah I'm I'm still down here
you know I'm I'm pretty staying now oh
oh and then hold on because I couldn't
keep going to my uh methadone clinic so
I tried to do heroin and it wouldn't
touch it you know I was on 100
milligrams of methadone it didn't do
[__] and uh so then I tried fetty and uh
it helped
so I try not to smoke too much of it you
know because
it's just [__] I already have one drug
going I get two [__] drugs going now
I'm smoking cigarettes again it's just a
[__] show it's a complete mess
but uh it's my mess where do you say now
uh you know what I actually through the
friend that brought me down here and uh
you know helped me
in my tent situation she also
coincidentally got me into the grand
which was really cool so tell the
viewers about the La Grande
it was a very nice hotel it is in
downtown L.A right just outside of skid
row outside yes it's outside it's good
and you uh and they took this beautiful
how many 13 24 Hotel uh yeah it's 12 12
floors and it's got like 400 there's 400
people living there no it's all
prior homeless people and so what's
happening in there was
we go in there and they house us they
feed us and
um and you know we work with a
coordinator to find housing so that's
basically what's going on but are you
allowed to use drugs while you're there
I mean are you ever allowed to use you
know sure we're all [__] junkies yes
we all yeah we all do so it's a
beautiful hotel full of full of drug
addicts fully drug addicts right and I
mean look there is people
that are you know
that are doing the thing and all that
and
but you know it's tough you know it's
really tough so
so yeah that's that's where I'm at
that's where I'm at how you support
yourself now
um
but selling stuff yeah are you boosting
stealing you know
not really you know what I'm actually
pretty good at panhandling
yeah I gave me 140 bucks the other night
yeah because I fly like a veteran sign
it's kind of one of those like hey
help me out
so but yeah panhandling yeah I mean have
I boosted yeah of course I boosted you
know I was on a boosting crew and all
that good stuff but I want to get too
into that you know
um but yeah I I will tell you that uh
there is a whole
economy of boosters and and vendors and
fencers and it's it's pretty amazing
really both here on skid row and
MacArthur Park yes sir absolutely yes
and like I said I mean I just don't want
to go too far down that road to uh
because
yeah but yeah it's pretty amazing it's
pretty amazing when you see like you
know the other thing I thought was
pretty amazing too is
you can go to any suburb in in in in the
US and in any neighborhood you know yeah
people know their neighbors but they're
not like talking to them every day but
when you live in a tent
with a bunch of other [__] that live
in a tent and you're all totally insane
you talk to each other every day all the
time all day off it's a very social it's
very social like experiment and and I
analyze and you know
I guess the other thing I should mention
is I was the basically the only uh white
guy on a predominantly black yeah
cracker is a very black there is yes
if you can survive there you can survive
anywhere yeah pretty much yeah it was a
good time though I really had a good
time a lot of um I miss it
and Jeremy what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life oh
most important lesson
you can always kind of you know turn it
around
it's never too late yeah I can see you
turning it around and oh yeah yeah
putting this behind you but I could
really [__] it up too
rip I can [__] [__] up really yeah and I
don't need any help I can really [__] it
up on my own pretty good
all right Jeremy thank you so much for
sharing thank you brother good luck all
right thank you